how many talented ones truly great
writers would you say have MFA's even
have a bachelor's versus those that
maybe don't do you think it's really
necessary gosh I don't know excuse me I
know someone who's just got a master's
and television writing from Loyola and
but I don't really know everyone's
resumes I think in these groups and what
they were into the nice thing about I've
noticed about people who go to college
and they get the screenwriting degrees
is when you're young you just don't have
that much to write about yet it's
because you haven't it's like a lot of
comedians don't get successful till
they're at least like 30 because they
just haven't done that much yet you just
need time on the planet and as a writer
the more time you have on the planet you
know the more you have to draw from so
that's a great thing about going to
college is that while you're young is to
learning you can learn the craft and the
technique so that when you do have more
things to write about you have the
technique you gotta get bitter first
yeah probably 35 is well writers yeah
writers are frequently there's a bit
even when they're successful there's a
bitterness writers when writers you get
together they just love to complain if
you're if you don't have an agent you
love to complain about you don't have an
agent when you do have an agent you
complain that they're not sending out
your stuff enough okay when you sell a
pilot you complain because the pilot
didn't get made when you get a pilot
made you complain because it didn't go
to series when you have a series you
complain that it only ran two years
instead of six years okay and I guess if
you're Chuck Lorre you complain that you
only have three series on the air
instead of six
I mean writers will always find a reason
to complain we're creative that way but
they voice what most people are already
thinking you know maybe they just don't
want to say it so those that are
embittered enough to say it yes we won't
say that but we want to we want to hear
it well that's a writer's job is to
voice things that people can't say
you